Tamera Mowry Housley is getting dragged
by Beyonce fans after reflecting on her
past
jay-z encounter watch out Tamera the
Beehive is buzzing and the sting is real
oh is it ever you guys know samara found
herself at the center of a bee storm
when she opened up on the real about
running into home at the Nutty Professor
two premiere back in 2000 the actress
turned talk-show host
dished on what surprised her most about
meeting the rapper take a look
I actually met jay-z in person okay and
he wasn't with Beyonce at the time and I
wasn't dating anybody
okay and when I met him you do get like
hit with the charm right I found myself
strangely asking for gum I met him it's
so weird
no I swear when I said sure I heard a
premiere a Nutty Professor and he walked
by and I was like oh my god that's jay-z
and I was like can I have some gone wide
Tamara I feel like she should have
learned her lesson The Beehive is so
savage we saw that with tonigh Lathan
and the bike gate and remember Becky
with the good hair Rachel Roy allegedly
oh you guys don't do it Tamara zero
co-hosts appear to be shocked that she
was opening up about being attracted to
the rapper in particular Loni love was a
mood she could tell that this story was
going downhill very fast
I told you I wasn't even I was 23
Oh Adam Adam wasn't even in the picture
yeah so Bearden - man
I don't know about that but I was
singing bad so we will attract it to the
loyal beehive naturally took to Tamera
social media to attack leaving lots of
be emojis one fan wrote you done rumbled
of the Beehive and another user gave
Tamera a pass for the story writing
sorry Tam the Beehive got a little too
excited but it's only because today is
the first day of spring and you just
happen to be a pretty flower and
Tamera's loyal fans came to her defense
writing it was a story little
simple-minded human beings everybody has
a past I mean to be fair that was almost
20 years ago both of them were single
but I feel like the part where Tamera
went wrong is that she kept going into
more and more detail about her
attraction to jay-z yeah less is more
fans have been protective of the
singer's relationship ever since she
dropped her infamous lemonade album
addressing J's infidelity in their
marriage yeah the tea was piping hot
there then jay-z also set the record
straight on marriage struggles releasing
his 444 album nobody wins wind of family
feels there's no real feud here Tamara
and jay-z are both happily married right
the Carters tied the knot in 2008 and
share our three kids Blue Ivy and twins
Rumi and surf and then Tamara married
Adam Housley in 2011 and they share two
kids she's been very open on the real
about how it was love at first sight
would Adam Adam is someone totally
different that I've ever dated before I
loved his confidence but not only that I
loved who he was as and is as a person
the first time I met him we love both of
these couples together so honestly I
think the Beehive just needs to back
down a little okay and don't come for
her I am The Beehive leader I feel like
Tamara just shared a little bit too much
here and this is in the past of course
we're gonna keep you updated with all
the latest so make sure you subscribe to
ET until the next time I'm Holly Stephen
and I'm Courtney teza know bye for now
guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]